MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
SANG KIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
-EA Sports.
It's in the game.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So
this is FIFA 13.
And I'm not a really
good player.
But I'm going to show you
what it looks like.
So let's get started.
As Sang said, it just came
out, end of September.
So let me play a quick match.
Kickoff.
Pick a team.
Sounds about right, Manchester
United versus Liverpool.
All right.
I can pick jerseys.
This sounds good.
So let's get started.
So first, this is a little bit
of a tutorial that shows you
how to play the game.
We can skip that.
Let's get rolling.
[VIDEO GAME AUDIO PLAYING]
-Let's get this one started
[INAUDIBLE].
-I've heard this [INAUDIBLE]
described as an exhibition
match.
There are no league
points this day.
But there isn't a single player
out there who doesn't
want to win.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
-Now for a throw.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I'm
really bad at this.
SANG KIM: [INAUDIBLE].
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes.
I get pretty aggressive
in this game.
So let me try to attack.
Yeah.
Ah.
-[INAUDIBLE]
with a tackle, and
he's got it.
It's a red card.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Ooh, red card.
Pretty bad.
OK.
So what I can do now is--
let's see.
Let me go ahead and go
through this one.
-The keeper's first
on the ball.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
I kick the ball.
-Goalkeeper clears his lines.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Let me pause it.
So I can hit Instant Replay
to see what happens.
So you see there is a
Play button here.
If I hit that, it shows
me this pass I
didn't do very well.
I can also change the
camera angle.
So I can actually change the
perspective that I want to see
it from, like maybe
from above.
Hit Play.
And then, if I'm happy with
it, I can hit the YouTube
button right there
in the corner.
And it asks me to confirm that
I agree that this content is
going to be syndicated
to YouTube.
And I'm fine with that.
I hit Agree.
So what happens next
is actually--
the game is going encode the
game play frame by frame.
So it's a kind of time
consuming process.
And then once it's encoded, it
uploads it to YouTube using
the YouTube APIs.
Let me show you what an example
game play looks like.
SANG KIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-We got the new Tiger Woods
'08, best game ever.
Got the new feature, you
can stand on the water.
You'll see.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SANG KIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
[TECHNO MUSIC]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-This group of Texas A&M
students have become a
national sensation
with their--
-Jaw dropping.
-Unbelievable.
-Pretty good, right?
-It's fun to watch.
-Mind blowing.
-Very impressive.
-Amazing, incredible basketball
trick shots.
-Take a look.
-Welcome to Aggieland.
This is the world's longest
basketball shot.
Yes!
What?
Oh, my god.
-Yeah!
-This is the Cowboy
Stadium shot.
-Yeah!
Cowboy Stadium!
-We found these guys
on YouTube.
-They call themselves
Dude Perfect.
-Dude Perfect.
-Dude perfect.
-These are our buddies
from Dude Perfect.
-Dude Perfect.
-And their videos are tearing
up the internet.
-Burning up the internet.
-There's talk of a video
game based on this.
Those deals are all
still long shot.
But of course, they've
made those before.
-Dude Perfect.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SANG KIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Thanks, Sang.
So I will talk a little bit
about YouTube APIs.
Has anyone in the audience
used the APIs yet?
If not--
all right.
So this is going to be very
introductory material for you.
So we have two sets of APIs,
data APIs and player APIs.
The use cases that Sang
demonstrated actually
use the data APIs.
So in order to upload a video to
YouTube directly from your
game, you can use
the data APIs.
And then player APIs are
used to customize
the playback behavior.
So not only you can upload to
YouTube, but you can also
integrate video playback
into your game.
So for example, if you have
Talking Tom, you may notice
that they actually have a
gallery where they're showing
a bunch of videos that
were uploaded from
the game in the game.
So let's talk a little
bit about how
you actually do that.
SANG KIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So data
APIs are RESTful.
And by that, I mean they're
based on HTTP.
They are very easy to use.
What you can do with them is
pretty much most of the things
you can do on youtube.com.
So most of the functionality you
see on YouTube is actually
exposed through the APIs.
In fact, if you use the
mobile YouTube app--
and I know a lot of people
in Korea do.
In fact, in Korea, more than
half of YouTube views come
from mobile devices.
If you use the mobile YouTube
app, you're actually using the
YouTube APIs already.
Because internally, our
application is built on top of
YouTube APIs.
And the way they work is
most of the entities
are exposed as feeds.
This is with API version two.
And we just launched API version
three, which makes
some modifications to it.
But the basic idea
is very similar.
Now, the player APIs allow you
to incorporate video playback
in your app.
So if you have embedded a
YouTube video into your blog
or in a web page, you
probably already
used the YouTube embed.
Now that can actually
be scripted
through an iframe API.
So in the web domain,
you can actually
customize the video playback.
And in the mobile domain, we
actually also allow this
either through the use
of HTML5 video--
so for example, if you use
iframe embed on iOS, you'll
notice that the video plays just
fine even though there is
no flash because we use HTML5
video on that platform.
And then for Android, we're
actually launching a new API
which allows you to integrate
the video playback directly
into your Android application.
It's Java based.
It's very easy to use.
So let me give you a couple
of examples of what
these things look like.
So for Apple specifically, as I
mentioned, the API is RESTful.
So this is an example upload
request, where I'm actually
issuing a post request with
some information about the
user obtained through OAuth.
So an access token is required
in order to do that.
And then I'm actually uploading
a WebM file.
And I will chat a little
bit about what WebM
is in the next slide.
And then I'm specifying the
metadata for the upload.
So as you see, I can add
a title, description
tags, and so forth.
So this is how the upload
is performed.
So again, this is something that
you can directly do from
your application.
You can either build the
request yourself, or we
actually have client
libraries.
So with version three of the
API, we have client libraries
for nine different programming
languages, including Java.
So if you're building a Java
application on Android, you
can use the client library.
We have an Objective-C client
library as well.
So if you're building an iOS
app, and you would like to do
video uploads directly from the
iOS app, you can use the
data API client library
to do that.
Now on the playback side,
here's an example of--
you might have seen the iframe
embeds that allow you
to embed the video.
But people don't know
that you can
actually script the playback.
So this is another way of
embedding a YouTube video,
where you instantiate an
instance of YT.Player, which
is a JavaScript object.
And then specify the video
that you want to play.
And in this code snippet,
I'm actually
registering event handler.
So when the player is ready,
I actually register an
onPlayerReady callback.
And then when player state
changes, I register
onPlayerStateChange callbacks.
So the way the API works is all
the state changes that are
actually happening while the
video playback is taking place
are actually propagated
to your application.
And you can register to them.
And you can react to them.
So in this very example,
actually I'm registering a
state change handler which will
automatically start video
playback as soon as this
player is initialized.
And then it registers a
timer which actually
fires after 10 seconds.
Once that timer fires,
I actually
stop the video playback.
So you can do things
like that.
And on Android, it's actually
much easier.
So I mentioned that we have
actually pre-announced the new
API at Google I/O--
and this is something that will
be launching soon-- where
all you need to do is include
a couple of packages in your
application, and then you can
programmatically load a video
and then play the video.
So all that is actually
available to your application.
Now this is the API that allows
you to actually upload
the video and then play the
video in your application.
How about the actual process
of video capture?
And this is where things get
a little more tricky.
In the examples that
Sang gave you-- for
example, Call of Duty--
they implemented the video
capture directly on the
console, same for the live
streaming example that Sang
was showing you a
little earlier.
The stream is actually captured
and encoded right on
the console.
In the example of a mobile
application,
here's a typical flow.
And I'll show you an example
of what this
looks like in a second.
But for example, if you're
building on top of Unity, you
can actually from Unity obtain
the audio and video frames, so
the raw frames.
And then you can encode the
frame using VP8 codec.
So this is technology that
we actually provide.
It's free and open source.
So Google acquired a company
called On2 Technologies a
while back.
And we actually accept WebM
uploads on youtube.com.
So if you want to use that
technology, you're
welcome to do that.
And so when video frames are
actually generated, you can
encode them using VP8.
For audio, we recommend
Vorbis.
Again, this is a free and
open source codec.
And you can do the same.
Once you have the encoded VP8
and Vorbis streams, you can
actually wrap them inside
of a container.
So WebM is the container that
actually is used to combine
the audio and video.
After that, you'll
have a WebM file.
Once that file is generated,
the rest is straightforward
because you can actually
use the data API
to upload to YouTube.
The requests look very similar
to what I showed you on the
previous slide.
So from then on, it's basically
a RESTful API where
you can push directly
to YouTube.
So this is the flow.
Let me switch to
an example app.
AUDIENCE: So in your slide,
you mentioned Unity.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So Unity's one
of the examples?
Or Unity's the only one?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: No.
So this is an example that
we implemented just to
demonstrate how you would
do it with Unity.
But I mean, you can implement
that on other engines.
I don't know about Korea.
But in the US, a lot of mobile
game developers use Unity.
So we find that this is
a good example to use.
The flow that actually this
application implements is
exactly this.
So this is something that we
were hoping to make available
to you soon as an open
source project.
So you can just play
around with it.
And we actually prototyped
this for Dude Perfect.
-You're good.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So you can
make your own trick shots
using the game and then share it
with your friends, who will
see the game play and then
hopefully download the game
and really spread the word.
Now, if you don't want to
implement this yourself, you
don't have to.
So there's a couple of companies
that are still
relatively new.
But they actually are trying to
make it much easier for you
to integrate the video
capture and upload to
YouTube in your game.
So you can either implement
the flow yourself--
and this is what I was showing
you, where you capture the
frames frame by frame.
You encode them.
You wrap them in
the container.
And then you upload
them to YouTube.
If you don't want to spend the
time doing that, there's
actually commercial,
off-the-shelf solutions to
that from the two companies,
Kamcord and Everyplay.
And what they do is they
actually provide you a set of
libraries that you can link
with that actually
take care of this.
They also have some advantages
in terms of performance.
So you might have noticed the
actual encoding process for
FIFA 13 is somewhat time
consuming because actually the
replay happens frame by frame.
They figured out a way
to do it much faster.
And here's a sample playback
done for Flip the Bird game
using Kamcord.
So you get the idea.
So now I'll let Sang talk
about best practices.
SANG KIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Do you
want to repeat it?
SANG KIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
AUDIENCE: I think the discussion
is, do they have to
develop their own encoding
to capture the screen?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So the actual
encoding is something
that we offer open source
software for.
So that's WebM VP8.
So for audio encoding and video
encoding, you don't have
to write that software.
What you do need to write is
the ability to capture the
frames, so the raw video,
raw audio frames.
Once you have that, you can pass
that into the encoder.
So on top of that, for
interesting titles, developers
typically like to build a replay
mode or theater mode,
much like what I showed you with
EA, where you change the
camera angles to slow
motion, like in the
Call of Duty example.
But really, the only thing that
the developer needs to
write is the ability to actually
capture the frames.
So whether you have your own
game engine, you can do that.
Or if you build on top of a
third party, some of them
provide that capability.
So for example, Unity
does this.
So it's reasonably
straightforward
to get these frames.
Now, the only challenge is
encoding is time consuming.
So then can you do that in a
way that is much faster?
This is where we see innovation
happening.
And the companies like Kamcord
or Everyplay, they're trying
to solve this problem so that
your game is not going to slow
down while you're trying
to capture.
So this is something they're
trying to do.
But if you don't want to deal
with any third party software,
you can take the open source
encoders and integrate it with
your application.
And then our API is free.
So you can just upload it
using the RESTful API.
SANG KIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
I think he's asking, what were
some of the case studies that
we've done outside
the game genre?
Lifestyle, television.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: As it
relates to uploads?
SANG KIM: Yeah.
Uploads.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
So one very interesting example
that we worked on is
in the news industry, so user
generated content for news.
And for that, we actually have
an open source project called
YouTube direct.
And that project comes with a
service side component that
runs on Google App
Engine and then
clients for iOS and Android.
They're open source.
And what they allow you to do
is to integrate video upload
directly into your
application.
So for example, a lot of
organizations, media
organizations, deploy it to
solicit user generated content
from their audience.
So then they can integrate it
into their own app or build a
standalone app.
And then videos actually are
captured using the camera,
uploaded to YouTube.
The server side component has
a moderation capability.
So the news organization can
decide which videos are
interesting.
The ones they approve end
up in the playlist.
And then they feature that
playlist on their website by
simply embedding the playlist.
So far as--
Another interesting use case for
user generated content--
news is really big.
I mean, a lot of news
organizations use that.
And videos nowadays break
a lot of news.
So a lot of stories are actually
started by a video
that goes viral.
Sometimes it's revolutions
that get started as well.
SANG KIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
SANG KIM: Is there a limit to
how much video [INAUDIBLE]?
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So there are
some practical limits.
But we have been actually
extending the length of the
video that can be uploaded.
So in the past, it was
five, 10 minutes.
Then we went to 15 minutes.
And now, if your account is in
good standing, we basically
have unlimited uploads.
And then there is a practical
limit for how large
the file can be.
I think last time I checked,
it was several gigabytes.
So I haven't actually seen a
case yet where somebody would
hit this problem.
What we do see is--
the best practice for this
type of integration is to
allow people to upload into
their own accounts.
So this is one constraint that
we do have in place.
And we actually recommended
it.
So rather than uploading it
into a single account, we
recommend the developers allow
the users to upload into their
own accounts.
And you can do that
using OAuth.
So you go through
the OAuth flow.
You authorize the application
for uploads.
And then when I play the game,
or when I perform the upload,
it actually ends up
in my own account.
And there's benefits to that
because actually we found that
content that is uploaded
directly into users' accounts--
it gets more views.
And it makes a lot of sense
because I want to share with
my friends.
AUDIENCE: But in that
case, users have to
have a YouTube account?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Good question.
So the question is, if users
upload to their accounts, do
they need to have a
YouTube account?
The answer is yes.
But it's actually sufficient
to have a Google account.
So if you have a Gmail address,
if you use Google
Docs, that's actually
sufficient.
Because we do have an API which
allows you to detect
whether they have a
YouTube channel.
And if not, you can create
one programmatically.
So really, the only thing they
need to have is they need to
have a Google account.
If they're on Android,
then they logged in.
So they already have one.
And then you can track using
the API, do they have a
YouTube channel?
Is not, you can create
one programmatically.
We also have a channel
suggestion API.
So you can show them the names
that are available.
For iOS, you would have to
basically go through OAuth
flow and have them log in
with a Google account.
To make that easier on iOS, we
have an open source project
called GTM.
And that implements a web
view based OAuth flow.
So you just include it into
your application.
And the entire authorization
flow is basically handled by
this component.
So that's something that
we have in place.
But fundamentally,
you're right.
You do have to have
a YouTube account.
But we've made it easier for
people that have Google
accounts to upload to YouTube
by introducing these
additional APIs.
SANG KIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
AUDIENCE: In addition to that
question, so once the user
uploads the video to their
own account, is
it public by default?
Or do they choose it?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes.
So the question is, once the
user uploads the video to
their account, is it
public by default?
It's actually up to you,
the developer.
So you can specify in the
metadata what should be the
visibility of the video.
By default, it will be public.
But you can change it.
And there's actually three
modes, public,
private, and unlisted.
So public videos are available
in our search index.
So you can look them up.
Private videos are not.
And only people that you
authorize can view them.
Unlisted videos are interesting
because you can
upload it as unlisted.
And no one can find it using
the search index.
But you can share the link.
So you don't need to log
in in order to view it.
So in fact, when I share family
videos with my family
who lives abroad-- my mother
lives in Poland.
And I send her videos
of my family.
I typically just send them--
I upload them as unlisted
because I don't want the whole
world to see my family videos.
And I just send her the link.
So there's actually three
different choices.
AUDIENCE: So but how do
the games do it now?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Typically,
as a developer, you want it
public because that gives you
greatest reach, right?
Ultimately, we're doing
it because we want the
distribution.
And if your friends don't see
the video, they won't be able
to click on the metadata
to download your game.
But the user has
total control.
So even if your game uploads it
as public, the user can go
back and change it.
So this is another reason why
we recommend uploading into
the users' channels.
Because for example, if I spent
the night playing a
video game, and I'll spend the
night all night long, my wife
can catch me that I was playing
it because I uploaded
it to YouTube.
Right?
So I can actually go back and
delete these videos before
it's too late.
Or I can make them private.
So that's something
that we recommend
is give user control.
So they don't feel like you're
doing something for them
without them having
any recourse.
But by default, set it up the
way it makes for your
application.
And then they can go to
youtube.com and very easily
change the visibility of those
videos if they are not proud
of it or they're trying to hide
it from their spouse.
SANG KIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: That's it?
All right.
SANG KIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]